je ne pense pas que marine le pen soit
aux portes du pouvoir
je pense qu'on est encore en train
d'organiser une grande peur qui
finalement profite au pouvoir je pense
qu'il y aura une pression maximale
d'abord si jamais si jamie marine le pen
était été dans cette position et et que
par ailleurs les gens qui ont voté pour
emmanuel macron en 2017 sont finalement
prêt je le pense
structurellement à recommencer parce que
il ya quelque chose là de profonds en
fait dedans dans la gauche dans cette
dans cette attitude
d'abord la gauche adorent se raconter
des comédies de résistance 2 et plus les
manifestations souvenez vous du 1er mai
2002 sont massives sont sont
conformistes plus le grand air de la
résistance et chanter fort donc ça je
pense que ça ça recommencera est
inéluctablement
c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
considère qu'il faut sauver le front
républicain n'est pas le front
républicain
malsain de l'entre-deux tours le front
républicain c'est maintenant le front
républicain c'est de proposer aux
français une politique qui s'adresse aux
classes populaires qui n'entre pas dans
la logique destructrice du vote
rassemblement national qui ne favorise
pas à la montée des sentiments
xénophobes et qui ne fracture pas le
peuple français entre entre communautés
entre ethnies et c'est maintenant que ça
se joue
certainement pas dans l'entre-deux tours
[Musique]